Narrator: We celebrate
the risk‐takers...
Why not quit the job
and go for it?
...the idea‐makers...
We can really change
the world together.
[ Screams ]
Narrator: ...the ones who
determine their own fate.
‐Whoo!
‐We got a deal!
Narrator:
We celebrate entrepreneurs.
I want y'all to think ‐‐
Who's next?
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
And tonight,
the American Dream continues.
Are you ready to help us
get the country
really hooked
on our smoked fish dip?
[ Laughter ]
Who's ready
to get their snuggle on?
This company only has one
direction to go, and that's up.
I think
you have something clever.
What are your sales?
$54,000.
‐[ Whistles ]
‐Oh!
John: You've been watching
"Shark Tank."
Where did we go wrong?
You've got so much work
to do.
It's always bad
when the Sharks
are redefining
your business plan.
You won't budge at all?
O'Leary: None! Zero!
'Cause you're giving me
no wriggle room here.
‐Oh!
‐I fell in love
with just wanting
to hang out with you guys.
I've got an offer for you.
Whoo!
"You never finish
what you start."
What?!
♪♪
Narrator:
First into the Tank
is a healthy version
of a local favorite.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Steve Markley,
aka "Captain Hooked."
And I'm James Arcaro,
the "Reel Assassin."
[ Laughs ]
We are here today
seeking $75,000
in exchange for 25% of our
company, Reely Hooked Fish Co.
Steve and I
are both Florida natives.
So we appreciate
a quality smoked fish dip.
Smoked fish dip
screams authentic Florida.
But we were sick and tired
of the mayonnaise‐
or cream‐cheese‐
dominated dips.
And we knew we had to
revolutionize the way people
eat and look
at smoked fish dip.
We went to work and created
a one‐of‐a‐kind recipe
that not only offers
an authentic flavor,
but it's healthy,
preservative‐free,
and it tastes phenomenal.
Introducing...
Both:
Reely Hooked Smoked Fish Dip.
Our product is
a delicious smoked fish dip
with a health twist,
because we use Greek yogurt
as a base.
We also added apples
to sweeten up the flavor
and give it
some sophistication,
which has
never been done before.
We have a multi‐day process
that includes
three primary phases
to deliver a superior product
to your table.
Both: Brine!
Smoke!
Mix it!
[ Laughter ]
Our smoked fish dip
is so fresh and unique.
Herjavec: Yeah!
And the best part is,
you don't have to feel guilty
for smashing
the entire container.
What?!
So, what do you say, Sharks?
Are you ready to help us
get the country
really hooked
on our smoked fish dip?
[ Laughter ]
Do it one more time!
‐Yeah, all right.
‐Do the smoked‐fish thing.
Sharks, are you ready
to help us get the country
really hooked
on our smoked fish dip?
[ Laughter ]
‐Whoo!
‐I mean. Like...
Thank you!
I'll be here all day!
‐That's funny.
‐All right, Sharks.
Are you ready to get hooked up
with some samples?
‐Yes!
That was the best ever!
‐Wow.
We were working on it
quite a while.
I got to hang out
with you guys.
‐Here we go.
‐All right, so...
Lori.
‐Thank you.
Are these all the same?
‐Oh.
‐Yes, it's the same dip.
‐Wow!
‐Yes.
‐Mmm.
It's good.
Really good.
What kind of fish is this?
It's mackerel.
King mackerel is what we use
because it's so oily
that it smokes well.
What does the yogurt
do for it? Less calories?
‐Yes.
Arcaro:
High protein, too.
So, in that container,
you're looking
at 245 calories.
245 calories?!
245 calories
in that whole container.
Only?
‐That's pretty cool.
‐Wow.
‐And 32 gr‐‐
‐The whole thing?!
‐Yeah.
‐32 grams of protein.
‐Wow.
‐Absolutely amazing.
Thank you.
I thought
it was unbelievably delicious.
‐Thank you.
How did you guys
come up with this?
Okay, we are also,
right now,
full‐time
wildland firefighters.
‐Wow.
There's the boys.
There we are, hard at work.
‐Wow!
‐Wow.
So, we actually met
through the fire academy.
We realized we had a lot
of the same interests.
You know ‐‐ involved
in businesses in the past.
We shared the same vision
for what we wanted in a company.
So we started running ideas
across each other.
And one ‐‐ one day,
this guy's like
"[Nasal voice] Hey, man,
what about smoked fish dip?"
Yeah. In ‐‐
In that ‐‐ In that...
I'm like, "Oh, my God."
I sounded just like that.
[ Normal voice ] Yeah, yeah.
Well, that's how he sounded ‐‐
So, you start the business.
What happens next?
We realized we didn't have
enough time or labor
to accommodate with the big
fire season we had in Florida.
And we said,
"We got to figure out
a better way to make money."
So we came up with a strategy
to go after breweries
because we think there's
a lot of foodies there.
Interesting.
Microbreweries.
Microbrewers and ‐‐ and,
yeah, craft breweries.
And it was just a good fit
for us.
So we targeted
three breweries.
Did they take it?
All three.
And how much of your sales
are to craft brewers?
About pretty much al‐‐
the whole thing.
We have one small retailer.
What sales do you have?
Okay. So...
S‐So, right now,
we're actually
super‐excited about it.
You know, we've sold $10,000
up to this point, but this is ‐‐
$10,000?
Yes.
Yes, $10,000.
In how many months?
In about three months.
Herjavec: Steve,
what do you sell it for?
What's one package go for?
So, a container,
it goes for $10,
is what we started.
Ohh.
But we believe that $12
is actually
a better price point now.
‐Yeah.
‐That's 10 bucks?!
That's probably
the most expensive dip
in the entire cooler.
‐Kevin.
Arcaro: It's not
the most expensive dip.
There is a product
that you ‐‐
It's not even
comparable to ours,
and they're selling
at that price point,
and they are selling.
Cuban: Look, either they're
selling, or they're not.
Steve, what does it cost you
to make one?
Right ‐‐ Right now, it's
costing us $4.50 a container,
but we can drive those prices
so far down
if we're buying the fish
in larger quantities,
we have the proper facilities,
and packaging.
S‐S‐‐ So, you're going
direct to the brewers?
Yes.
So, I cut you a check
for $75,000.
‐Yeah.
‐What happens tomorrow?
We would put that towards
the proper equipment,
a lit‐‐
a better facility.
Do you need this money
to replace your salaries,
basically,
so you can focus on it?
Is that the idea?
Yes.
We want to move into
this business full time.
John:
You know, I fell in love
with just wanting
to hang out with you guys.
All right?
I love the product.
But at this point,
three breweries ‐‐
You're really too early
for me to get it to scale,
and I would have to see
way more evidence
that you're capable
of scaling the company.
So I'm out.
Markley: Okay.
Thank you.
You're not answering
the question for me.
How do you go from $10,000
in sales to more?
Tell me
the next three steps.
We rescale it
with restaurants.
So, once we're in restaurants,
we want to be able to buy
some ‐‐
some refrigerated trucks.
And I have no problem
going out
and selling this business
and ‐‐ and getting...
You can't get this into Publix
or something like that?
We could.
We absolutely could.
Cuban: But they can't
keep up with it, yeah.
‐We ‐‐ We ‐‐
‐They couldn't take the order.
Yeah.
‐Absolutely.
Greiner: I want to tell
you guys something.
I love your logo,
but I think
that people in our country
love to get behind
our everyday heroes,
people who go out
and risk their lives
every day for all of us.
If you could incorporate it,
like the "Hook and Ladder
Fish Company"
or something like that.
That's a great name.
Well, what are
you gonna do, Lori?
This product will sell.
People want it.
This is not
a saturated shelf space.
Look.
We have
an amazing opportunity here.
If it were entrepreneur
and fantastic flavor and taste,
then I have a lot of weight
on this side of the scale.
But if it was difficulty
of the business,
and can we really scale it,
and the scale goes
a little bit like this for me.
And it's a little heavier
on that more difficult side.
I'm so sorry, but I'm out.
$10,000 in sales.
It's nothing.
Yeah, but we ‐‐ Listen.
Guys, let's be honest.
You threw a mackerel
in a blender
and said
it was worth $300,000.
I'm out.
We represent
the American Dream.
That's who we are.
That's what we are.
‐You're right.
‐That's for sure.
‐You do.
‐We're not coming here
with millions
of dollars of sales.
We're coming to you with
a product and an opportunity
to be at millions of dollars
in sales.
I understand
the path isn't easy.
It hasn't been
since I was a child.
Okay, guys, guys, guys.
Okay.
Answer these questions 'cause
here's where I'm uncertain.
You're basically doing $1,000
per month, per restaurant.
About that. Correct.
And so if you can get
to 25 restaurants,
then you're gonna do
$25,000 a month,
plus whatever you do
on the side, right?
Yes.
Now, do you guys have enough
time to get the 25 restaurants?
Well, we're ‐‐ Yes.
We're gonna work this thing
full time.
Okay.
Are you guys able to go slow?
We've been so patient
getting here.
Yes.
‐If you stay patient...
‐We're methodical.
I'm interested if you guys
can go from 3 to 5
to 7 to 10
and still prove that you're
gonna do $1,000 a week.
Mm‐hmm.
Can you do that?
Absolutely.
That's of interest to me.
Let me give you an example, too,
of just something
we go through
in this company.
Yo, yo, yo, yo.
Yeah.
I said I was interested,
right?
Yeah. Yes.
Yes.
Sometimes the best way to
close a deal is to shut up.
Right? Okay.
I'm gonna make you
a very Sharky offer.
Okay.
All right.
75K for 25%.
Well, that's what
they asked for.
I know.
So, are you guys in?
It's either
a "yes" or "no."
‐You got a deal!
‐Oh, my God!
‐Whoo!
‐Yeah!
‐Oh, dude!
‐There you go.
‐Oh, my God!
‐Reel in Mark!
Reel in Mark!
‐Here, Mark. You ready?
‐Ready.
‐Ready?
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: I don't think
I can jump like that anymore.
‐Ah.
‐I love it!
Congrats, guys.
Make this work.
‐Oh, my gosh, man. Thank you.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐My pleasure.
‐Yeah, we will.
‐Whoo‐hoo‐hoo‐hoo!
‐See you guys. Thank you.
All right! Whoo!
Whoo!
We did it, dude!
Yeah!
Whoo!
[ Laughing ] Oww!
Yes!
We got a deal
with Mark Cuban!
Yeah!
Whoo!
[ Both laugh ]
You ready?
Yeah, I'm ready.
Let's hook up America!
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Narrator:
Next up is a product
designed
for the do‐it‐yourself groomer.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Joshua Esnard.
I'm here from
Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
And I'm the inventor
of The Cut Buddy.
Today, I'm seeking $300,000
in exchange
for 10% of my company.
Whoo!
Sharks, you know what?
Cutting your own hair...
Daymond, you ever cut
your own hair?
‐I have.
‐Cutting your own hair ‐‐
That's no easy task.
One wrong move,
and it can all be over.
‐[ Laughs ]
[ Sighs ]
Bro.
Oh, my goodness.
What did you do, man?
What happened?
Oh, man!
Pushed back his hairline.
‐Oh!
Oh, no!
But you know what?
It doesn't have to be
this way...
because I created
the solution.
It's called The Cut Buddy.
Here you go, brother.
Use this instead.
All right?
The Cut Buddy
is the first multi‐curve
hair‐grooming guide tool
that allows you to edge up
and shape up your beard lines
and your hairlines
perfectly and quickly.
With three curves
and three straight edges,
you can look great,
regardless of your head shape
or your hair size.
See?
That's a better curve.
Keep using The Cut Buddy.
O'Leary: Yeah!
You should have used that
from the beginning.
All right! Oh, yeah.
All right?
And for our beautiful
bearded model friend here...
The Cut Buddy
works perfectly for beards.
All you need to do is put the
product against your beard line
and let it guide you
to the perfect look.
See, there's no more
second‐guessing.
You can now cut your hair
with confidence.
You can look great.
People will stop you
on the street and say,
"Hey, who cuts your hair?!"
Great job, Joe.
Joe, who cut your hair?
[ Laughter ]
That The Cut Buddy difference
there.
So, Sharks,
who wants to cut a deal?
‐Ohh!
‐Oh.
I have some samples.
I want to see him cut
your hair, Kevin.
Listen, it's very,
very delicate lines.
[ Laughs ]
‐There you go.
‐Thank you.
Did you create
your little character here?
Esnard: Yeah.
It's all created by me.
So, I did
all the packaging myself.
Tell us about you.
Sure.
I am actually an immigrant
from a developing country
called St. Lucia.
Maybe some of you
have visited.
‐Yeah, it's beautiful.
‐Of course.
‐Beautiful country.
‐Yes.
‐Beautiful.
‐My parents had me very young.
They were trying
to make a better life.
They moved to America.
But if you know anything about
old‐school immigrant parents,
you're getting
one type of haircut.
And that's the buzz cut.
So, I was getting ready
to go to middle school.
I wanted to get the girls.
I wanted to wear
my Platinum FUBU.
No doubt, no doubt.
Good man.
And I wanted my haircut ‐‐
my haircut to look nice.
So I didn't want
my dad cutting my hair.
I tried to cut my own hair.
And I jacked it up many times.
So I went and started designing
all kinds of products
that can help me.
And I actually cut up
my dad's folders
and created the first Cut Buddy
when I was 13 years old.
‐Good for you.
‐Wow.
I actually sat on this invention
for 15 years
before I patented it.
What was the catalyst to go
from letting it lie
to starting the business?
So, my girlfriend and I,
we're trying to move
the treadmill into the garage,
and it won't fit.
So we took the door
off the hinges,
fit the treadmill in,
and then she's like, "All right,
put the door
back on the hinges."
I'm like,
"Uh, that was a lot of work."
She's like, "You never
finish what you start."
It hit my heart, and I thought
I wasn't showing up for my life.
So I went to my inventor book.
And ‐‐ Hold on.
♪♪
I've had an inventor book
for many years.
And the first page
of my invention book is...
The Cut Buddy.
And you have a patent
on it?
Yes.
I actually have two patents.
And do you still have
the girlfriend?
She's my fiancée now,
and we're expecting a baby
in a week or two.
‐Wow!
‐Oh, my gosh.
Cuban: So you're gonna have
to sell a whole lot of these.
Give me the time frame
from that epic moment
to you standing here.
I've been open, in business,
since January 2016.
So, why don't
you give us sales for 2016
and what you project
for 2017
to help me get over the hump
on this $3 million value?
My sales for 2016
were $700,000.
‐Yes, sir!
‐What?!
‐Wow!
‐Get out of here!
‐Josh delivers!
‐60,000 units.
‐Yeah.
‐Oh, yeah.
Esnard:
60,000 units have left ‐‐
Where did you sell
60,000 units?!
How did you do that?
I've found some affiliates
on YouTube
that had a heavy following
doing videos for hair.
And all of a sudden, my sales
went from 20 sales per day
to 100, 200, 400 sales per day.
And I went viral on Facebook,
hit 11 million views.
Wow!
What do you sell it for?
I sell it at $14.95.
And we wholesale
at the $8.50 price point.
What does it cost you?
It's $2 with the back of it.
Daymond:
And where does it retail?
Is it hair places
like Sally's?
Or is it Walgreens, CVS,
or all of them?
I met with Sally's.
I'm just waiting basically
for them to offer me a P. O.
Target and Walmart
has brought us on as a dot‐com.
But, yeah, that's the retail
area that we want to go to.
But most of the sales now
are direct to consumer?
Correct. Maybe 20% of my sales
are to wholesale clients,
and then the rest
are right to consumer.
What do you need us for?
Because...
I think that the mentorship
that you guys can give me
as a strategic partner
can help me.
You have to realize
that I'm an inventor.
I invented a product
that went viral.
So, basically, I had a baby
that's learning how
to drive a car now. I ‐‐
With $300,000, you can go
and date 17 mentors
at $10,000 a month,
then pick the one you want.
‐Yeah.
‐So...
And ‐‐ And you don't
have to share the rest
of your profits...
Well...
...for the rest of your life
with it.
Daymond, are you trying
to talk yourself out of a deal?
I ‐‐
I'm not trying to talk myself
out of a deal,
but I want to ask the question,
because if he turns around,
and we can't do better
than he's doing for him,
what's gonna happen?
I heard him ask for $300,000.
So I'm prepared to make you
an offer.
It's not really a business.
It's a product
with a good entrepreneur
that hustles underneath it.
I'll give you
the $300,000.
What I want is $1.50
from every unit
until I've made back
a milskie.
Basically, just over
three times on my money.
Then that goes away.
And just so I can keep
my interest in you,
I want 5% of the company.
Josh,
I'll throw a sweetener in.
Josh, wait a minute.
If you do this deal with me,
I'll grow my hair back.
[ Laughter ]
‐Oh, man!
‐You know.
Just to clear the deck,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
Congratulations, man.
It's just...
I could have helped you
re‐billionize.
‐"Re‐billionize"?
‐Ah.
That's a good one.
Josh, I think
it's a good product.
I don't ‐‐ I don't
really understand it,
to be honest with you.
And ‐‐ And it ‐‐
it worries me that ‐‐
To me,
it's so self‐evident.
You got to go online,
you got to hustle it out there,
and you want
to go into retail.
I don't want to have
that argument with you.
I'm out.
I‐I honestly think that
this will be as common as a comb
in your house
in the next five years.
Maybe.
For sure.
Daymond: As far as templates,
that means there are
other templates out there?
So, I've been knocked off
more than 700 times.
Similar products?
O'Leary:
Josh, you know there's a risk.
But are there other ones
prior to that?
‐That's really staggering.
‐No. I'm the first.
I'm the father of the industry,
and they caught on to it
and started knocking ‐‐
Being knocked off
just tells you ‐‐
It's a confirmation
of the product, okay?
I'm all right with that.
But I made you an offer,
and you're still talking
to people
that don't seem that excited.
Daymond, I see you're quiet,
and I...
What are you doing, Daymond?
You're one of my idols.
And I love your story.
Is there any way
that you and Kevin
would work together in this?
Wh‐‐ Work with Kevin?
Why would I do that?
I mean,
he's a beautiful guy.
I have more hair
than he has!
[ Greiner laughs ]
No matter what side
of the table we're up at here,
we're ‐‐ we're here to fight
for the entrepreneur, right?
So I don't want to put
a burden on you,
but if there are places
you think I can add value ‐‐
Of course
I relate to the product.
You know, you're gonna be
a new dad right now.
Every decision you're
gonna make from this point on
is not gonna be
about you.
It's gonna be about
two other very important people.
Are you thinking
about that?
Because the day you become
a father, life changes.
I just want to do good
for my child
[Voice breaking]
who's being born.
And I just...
Sometimes I just feel lost
'cause I feel like
I'm just an inventor
and I'm not really
a business owner, totally.
I work my ass off,
but sometimes I just feel lost.
And I feel like you guys
are, like, the flashlight
that can help me get
into wherever
that I need to be, you know.
I'm just gonna
let you know ‐‐
There's 28 million small
businesses in this country.
And over half of them
are operated
by one‐man
and one‐woman shops.
And they're the backbone
of our country.
They're more valuable
than people ever
give them credit to be.
So, you're here already.
You know,
I've got an offer for you.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Kevin has an offer on the table
for The Cut Buddy,
a trimming guide
for home haircuts.
But Daymond is also interested.
I'll offer you $300,000
for...
for 20%.
And, trust me, you know
I would normally say 33 1/3%.
There are, to me, traits
to a great entrepreneur ‐‐
drive, passion,
not giving up.
You have
all of those traits...
Thank you.
...to do all these different
things, as they said.
But you also have
two good offers here.
So I'm out.
♪♪
Thank you, Lori.
O'Leary: So, Josh...
three Sharks out,
two offers on the table.
What are you gonna do?
♪♪
Daymond, is there any way
that you'd go to 12.5%?
Ohh!
I like that about you.
But I would normally be
at 33%.
$300,000 for 20%,
I think, is fair.
It gets me excited.
I go out there, and I‐I do
whatever you need me to do.
♪♪
Josh, you have to make
a decision, my friend.
♪♪
You know what?
Daymond, I'm gonna ‐‐
I'm gonna ride with you.
‐Oh, man.
‐Congratulations.
‐Good job.
All right, brother.
Thank you, man.
Congratulations.
‐Aww!
‐Congrats, Josh.
‐Congratulations.
‐I can't wait to work with you.
‐You gonna be a good dad.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Congratulations.
‐Congrats, man.
‐Good luck to you.
Whoo! Yeah!
Daymond!
[ Chuckles ]
Yes!
I'm gonna make sure
that my family ‐‐
all the way from my parents to
my grandma ‐‐ are taken care of,
because that's all that matters.
They took care of me.
We're from a developing country
called St. Lucia.
[ Voice breaking ] And we had
a long ride to America.
And we made it.
We made it, Mom!
We made it!
We made it, Dad!
Kristen, I love you.
[ Crying ]
♪♪
Narrator:
In Season 4, Aaron Krause
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for his innovative kitchen
sponge, the Scrub Daddy.
Let's see how he's doing now.
Krause: When we originally went
on "Shark Tank,"
we only had one product.
And now our product line
is over 30 deep.
The Scrub Daddy is now sold
in over 60,000 retail stores
in the United States
and about 3,000 in Europe.
[ Speaking German ]
Seeing our growth in Europe
validates that our product
is acceptable around the world.
Soon we'll expand to Asia
and even South America.
When I did my deal with Lori,
we only had about $100,000
in retail sales.
And now
we've broken $141 million!
Guess who!
After Lori and I
did a deal on "Shark Tank,"
I began to show her
some of my other inventions.
And one of them was a dish wand
that looked like a flower.
When I first showed her
one of our prototypes,
she told me
it looked like a toilet brush.
So we went back
to the drawing board.
The final product has arrived.
And I can't wait to open it
together with Lori.
Scrub Daisy.
[ Gasps ]
Oh, it turned out
so perfect!
Greiner:
I really love Scrub Daisy.
It's different than any other
wand because it's beautiful
and it works better than
anything else on the market.
I think every kitchen in America
is gonna have one of these!
Aaron and I
have done so much together.
I'm so proud to see how the
entire business keeps evolving.
And the two of us together ‐‐
Well, there's no stopping us!
Krause: I'm extremely proud
to represent "Shark Tank"
as one of
the most successful businesses.
The show has given me
a platform ‐‐
not just to build my brand,
but to inspire and educate,
and even create
new entrepreneurs in the U. S.
Together: Scrub Daddy!
Yay!
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a soothing
toy and educational tool
for small children.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Callie Christensen.
And I'm Kelly Oriard.
We are here seeking $175,000
for a 5% stake
in our company, Slumberkins,
Sharks, think back
to when you were 5 years old.
How many of you had a favorite
stuffed animal or blanket
that was so special you
just couldn't live without it?
That one thing
that you took everywhere.
And it made you feel safe.
As moms and educators,
we know that kids attach to
things that comfort and soothe.
So we designed
a line of cuddly creatures
that are a hybrid between
a stuffed animal and a blanket.
We call it a lovey.
We use only
the softest materials.
And kids just can't help but
snuggle up to our Slumberkins.
They're magical friends
that last through lifetime,
giving a feeling of safety,
love, and security throughout.
Now, because I'm a school
counselor and she's a teacher,
we knew that Slumberkins
could also help teach
important life skills.
So each one comes with a book
that focuses on those skills
that we teach
in the school every day.
We are cuddly creatures
with intention.
And we are on a mission
to promote positive skills
in the next generation
and beyond ‐‐
one cuddle at a time.
Who's ready
to get their snuggle on?
Yes, of course.
Okay.
We have the Yeti.
Thank you.
Pink! [ Laughs ]
What did you get, Daymond?
Oriard: Daymond,
you're holding our Yeti.
His story is all about
a mindfulness practice
for children.
Thank you.
Lori, you're holding our Fox.
Aww.
The story focuses on helping
kids cope with big change.
Mr. Wonderful,
you have our shark.
His story is
all about conflict resolution.
And we would hope that you could
learn something from that story.
O'Leary: Wow.
Conflict resolution.
Oriard: Mark,
you're holding our Bigfoot.
His story is all about positive
affirmations and self‐esteem.
Aww.
And, Robert,
you're holding our Sloth,
who's all about relaxation.
Sloth!?
‐Yeah!
‐Relaxation.
Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
I'll take Sloth.
Okay.
‐Would you like a Yeti?
‐Now, Robert...
‐Yes!
‐Oh. Okay.
‐Robert.
‐Robert, stop being bad.
‐Get the man a Yeti.
‐Slow down, slow down.
I can totally see you
as a little kid!
Yeah, you need some
conflict resolution, Robert.
‐Thank you.
‐Wow!
"Let's help Hammerhead calm down
and then make it right."
So, how did you come up
with the way that it looks,
the texture, all of that?
We really wanted to make
something that was more unique
than anything out there
on the market.
And, also, we use a fabric
that isn't typically found
in the toy industry.
It's more
in the fashion industry.
We've been in business
for about 18 months.
Callie and I were making these
by hand in our homes,
taught ourselves to sew,
put some online,
and found
that we had a demand.
We each invested $200
into fabric, to begin.
Yes.
So that was our ‐‐
That's it?
Yeah.
‐So you're all in?
‐For $200?
‐Yes.
‐$200.
‐Yeah.
Oriard: As an educator,
we were all in.
‐That's what I mean.
‐$200. Yes.
We were pulling from savings
for that.
So, the next six months
was really about trying
to meet the demand
that we had created
through our social media.
And so we started hiring
local seamstresses
and created our own cuddly
creature manufacturing empire
in Vancouver, Washington.
What do you sell it for?
So, currently, they retail
between $44 and $52.
‐Wow.
‐Wow!
Greiner: Wow!
What's it cost you
to make one?
Currently, they cost $15
to make.
[ Whistles ]
That's a lot!
How did you create
the demand?
It's all been driven
through social media.
We have a very engaged
Instagram following.
It almost sells itself
once a mom gets it,
and then she takes a picture
of their ‐‐ her sleeping...
Her kid.
...child with it.
What are your sales?
Well, in our first year,
we did $200,000.
And, this year,
what do you think?
This year,
we're projected to do over ‐‐
a little over half a million.
‐Nice!
‐Wow.
Wow.
We basically have capped out
on what we can produce here
in the United States, and...
Oh, so you're constrained
on inventory?
We're constrained
by what we are making.
So you're not manufacturing
these overseas?
No.
Knowing what our sales
are at,
we completely know
that our valuation
might be a little high,
but it's because we know
that we're capped out
in this production holding,
as you will, for right now.
So you're asking
for what you need,
not necessarily what
the business is worth?
Well, we think
it's worth that
because we did not
meet demand this year.
We believe that we are going
to sell a lot more in 2018.
Okay.
And we actually have solved
that problem
and found
an amazing production partner.
It'll reduce our costs
by 2/3.
Really?
So, your costs
are gonna be, what, $6?
Mm‐hmm.
Are you planning to stay
only on your website?
No. So, our goal is to get
into the hands and hearts
of as many children
as we can.
And so, that's part of
why we're here.
But what's your vision
for how to do that?
What ‐‐ Do you want
to go into retail?
Yes. We would like
to move into retail,
but this is
part of why we're here.
We know that you guys
have expertise.
Premium plush
is really tough.
Cuban: Yeah,
but, guys, guys, look.
This brings
a fundamental question.
Yes.
Your margins are gonna go up,
let's say, 80%,
'cause you're selling directly
from your website, right?
‐Mm‐hmm.
That's a good thing.
You know?
And if you keep on ‐‐
So you're recommending
not to go to retail?
Well, that ‐‐ And that's
my question, right?
You're making a killing.
Mm‐hmm.
And if you slow‐grow it
and keep things
a little bit constrained,
you're gonna make really,
really, really good money.
When you try to scale
like that,
a whole new set
of problems arise.
Yep.
A whole new concept
of how you're funding it
and how you're going
to pay for that.
Are you sure
you want to do that?
Yes.
You might not make
as much money.
Your profits could go down.
Now, with our costs
being lowered,
we feel it's important
that we do make it
an accessible product
because of our history
as educators.
So you want to lower
your price?
We would like to, yes.
Okay.
Do you think it's the
right business decision?
What would you lower it to?
I think that's where
we need expertise and help
moving forward so we enter
the retail market strategically.
Would you rather reach
more kids or make more money?
At this point,
we want to move forward
and reach
as many people as we can.
That's fair enough.
But then you have to change
your business plan,
because you can't compete
at $52 in the plush category.
I'm going to guess
that 99% of plush toys
sell for under $9.99.
This is the 1%, okay?
Yeah, but this isn't
just a plush toy.
You're teachers.
You've built a brand.
It's online.
People are talking about it.
And they're giving you
52 bucks.
We're saying we want
to very strategically enter
into a relationship
in the bigger space
to make them
more accessible.
Like, we're really interested
in ‐‐ in Amazon.
Well, that's still online, yeah.
That's still online.
Yeah.
‐Yeah.
And, you know,
it's not ‐‐ It's ‐‐
It's not for us
to write your business plan.
We're just trying
to give you advice and...
‐Yeah.
‐Yeah, I know.
‐You can assess risk, Daymond.
‐At the end of the day...
‐We appreciate it.
‐Huh?
‐You can assess risk.
‐Yeah.
I'm gonna tell you
my risk.
I was in the plush business
a couple years ago.
And I realized
how brutal it is.
And the companies
that are in this area,
they are making them
in mass,
they're driving
the price down.
And I do not want to take
that journey again,
because I'm still licking
my wounds from the first time.
I'm out.
Thank you.
It's always bad
when the Sharks
are redefining
your business plan.
But it's painfully obvious
to me the only way this works
is if you stay up there
in the 1% or 2%
and you just keep doing
what you're doing ‐‐
expanding your story online
and selling direct to customers.
It's not worth
$3.5 million.
It's not even worth
a million yet.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you, Kevin.
Cuban: Hey, guys.
Look, what you've
accomplished so far is great.
And, actually,
your scarcity
has worked to your favor
significantly.
The hard part comes next.
And you've got
so much work to do.
Yes.
You've got product,
you've got pricing,
you've got distribution,
you've got scale, and you've
got your social mission...
Yep.
...which is great.
The problem
is that 5% of the company
to try to help you do
all those things ‐‐
You'd have to be
a $200 million company
before I saw any return
on my time.
So I have to say
I'm out.
Thanks, Mark.
Thank you.
But congratulations on
what you've accomplished.
Thank you.
I love your mission.
And I like the idea
of soothing things for kids.
But, as an investment
for me,
I like things that are
a little bit more unique.
I don't ever feel it's
as wise to go up against
a lot of competition
in the same arena.
Yeah.
Mm‐hmm.
And so, while I love
both of you,
I don't love
all the competitiveness,
so I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
I think
it's a great mission.
And from a great mission
comes a great product.
Mm‐hmm.
I don't know
why you want to expand it.
I believe
in what you're doing today.
in this direction.
Okay.
It's a slow burn!
Mm‐hmm.
You're not gonna sell
as much as you want,
but you're gonna make
more money!
Yeah.
Cuban: And you'll be able
to do more things.
‐Mm‐hmm.
‐Yeah.
Herjavec:
I can't get in on it today.
Thank you for being teachers,
but I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thank you guys
for your time.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thanks for your time.
‐You guys have been great.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you, guys.
52 bucks for a plush toy?
That's extraordinary.
But it's not a plush toy.
And they're doing
a great job online.
Well, in the end,
I have bad news for you ‐‐
It's a plush toy.
Oriard: I really thought
somebody would understand
the mission behind it
and want to get it
to as many kids
[Voice breaking]
as ‐‐ as we can, you know.
Yeah.
[ Breathes deeply ]
We're still gonna do it.
We're gonna not stop.
No.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product
that provides
an ice‐cold beverage
exactly when you want it.
♪♪
Sharks, my name
is Alexander Simone.
I'm an inventor
from San Francisco.
I'm here today seeking $100,000
as an investment
for 5% of my company,
Pronto Concepts.
My invention solves a problem
that millions of wine lovers
all over the world
face every day.
Wine lovers
love their wine chilled.
They also love their wine
in the moment.
But the best spontaneous
beverage, ironically,
requires the most preparation
and foresight.
That's why I invented ProntoBev.
♪♪
Behold, the world's
fastest wine chiller.
As soon as you pour any bottle
into ProntoBev,
the wine‐grade
stainless‐steel interior
jump‐starts
a rapid heat‐transfer process.
Sommeliers, or wine experts,
recommend
that each variety of wine
be chilled
to its own specific temperature,
which truly unlocks
the flavors within.
ProntoBev's built‐in thermometer
monitors your wine
so you get that perfect
temperature every single time.
ProntoBev can chill bottle up to
20 degrees in just 30 seconds.
Before ProntoBev,
the only way to choose
from your wine collection
and enjoy immediately
was to own a wine refrigerator.
Well, there we have it ‐‐
perfectly chilled wine.
So, Sharks,
when it comes to your wine,
and when it comes
to your money,
would you be waiting around?
Or do you need it, pronto?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐All right.
All right, would one of you
like to come up and check out
the before and after version?
‐I do.
‐Come on up.
And just to let you know,
this prototype's
actually not food‐grade,
but it should be safe.
I drink from it
all the time, like I said.
‐"It should be safe"?!
[ Laughter ]
Herjavec:
Is it cold, Kevin?
It's beyond chilled.
It's ‐‐ It's cold.
Is it
the right temperature?
It's the right temperature
for a white.
All right, could I have
some wine, please?
I'll be your server.
Okay, continue with the pitch.
But you drank out of that.
Daymond, do you want a glass?
Please. Thank you.
Mark?
‐Sure. Why not?
‐Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
Mr. John.
Thank you.
Mr. Cuban.
So, you were saying you don't
have, like, the right one here?
Right. Correct.
Right?
So, is this not even
in production yet?
It's not in production yet.
What's the material that
holds the temperature delta?
Behind the stainless steel
is our trade‐secret Pronto gel.
Is that patented?
We have a provisional patent
on it, yes.
Okay.
How did you come up
with this idea?
I was back in college,
trying to drink a bottle
of wine with a girl,
and the wine was warm.
So me being kind
of, like, the inventor type,
I grabbed a pasta strainer,
I filled it with ice,
poured the wine through,
and amazingly, the wine
was super‐cold super‐fast.
And we go to drink the wine,
and it was
just horribly disgusting.
When you did that,
you also diluted
the wine with the ice.
I ruined the wine, yeah.
Are you still
with the girl?
So, that ‐‐ that is a huge issue
in chilling white wines.
This doesn't dilute it,
which is a good thing.
And I know that
because I'm a member
of the Chevaliers
du Tastevin.
And we care about
the temperature of our wines.
‐Yeah.
‐I'll drink to that.
Simone: Excellent.
[ Laughter ]
‐You chevalier.
‐I'll drink to that.
To the chevalier.
‐C'est tu bon.
‐Cheers.
I'll have some of the ‐‐
some of the warm wine.
‐Absolutely.
‐Yeah.
Okay, can you tell us
where you're at with sales?
Simone: Yes.
So, we just finished
our Indiegogo crowdfunding
campaign yesterday,
and we raised $54,000.
What were you looking for?
$25,000.
And what does it cost?
On crowdfunding, it's $89.
When we're actually selling it,
we'll sell it for $129.
Ohh!
The cost is $22 to make.
So, if you're positioning
this product
as a wine chiller, basically,
why do you have to put it
back in the bottle?
The way we can get it
to chill so quickly,
it basically is like
a cannon blast of cold.
That's ‐‐
You're saying it freezes
if you leave it inside it?
It won't freeze, but the
temperature will keep dropping.
With any alcoholic drink,
there's a perfect temperature.
And just to let you know,
all the temperatures
are written
right on the packaging.
Thank you very much.
So, you seem to know
a lot about wine.
What's your background?
I actually studied
entrepreneurship.
Where at?
At Arizona State.
I came up with this idea,
like I said.
I've worked for other start‐ups
in the past,
but I've known my entire life
that I was gonna do
something like this.
So, I have no idea
why people
aren't really going over
this valuation.
So, let's look at the
crowdfunding platform you're on.
You only sold
$54,000 worth.
In two months.
The first two months.
Do you have some other stuff
that's gonna give us a reason
to get
to a $2 million valuation?
There is another reason.
So, one
of our biggest competitors,
they're also a wine chiller,
but they take way longer,
and there are other drawbacks
to the product
that ProntoBev has a lot
of advantages over.
What does
the competition cost?
What does it cost?
They charge $80.
They're doing how much
in business?
$10 to $20 million a year.
$10 million to $20 million.
That's a big ‐‐ big swing.
‐That's a big range.
‐Yeah.
But ‐‐ So, you believe
that that's why
you're worth $2 million?
I see our product as being
worth far more than that.
All right.
You've been watching
"Shark Tank."
Where did we go wrong?
Why do you think
we would ever invest
in a company at this level
with
a $2 million valuation?
This company has only one
direction to go, and that's up.
Well, then I've failed you,
because I, obviously,
am not giving
the right lessons here
and the right information...
because I don't want you
to go into another room
and make a stupid mistake
like that.
This valuation is crazy.
I'm out.
Cuban: Okay, one
of the challenges I have
when working
with inventors ‐‐
When you're an inventor first
and an entrepreneur second,
you want to invent.
Yeah.
But the harder part
is turning it into a company
that's profitable enough
to make it worthwhile.
Valuing this company
at $2 million ‐‐
I just don't see that.
I don't see it going there.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
Oh, that hurts, Mark.
You would have been
a great partner.
Sorry.
I appreciate that.
All right. I understand.
Herjavec:
Alexander, look...
you know, a great product
that you're
very passionate about
doesn't make
a great company.
And your valuation
isn't trivial.
It's just way too soon
for me.
I mean, I‐I'm out,
but I‐I think the only person
that would be interested
would be a wine expert.
What do you call
a wine expert?
A ‐‐ A?
Chevalier du Tastevin.
‐Hey!
‐Ohh!
A great reason
to toast.
Okay, Alexander.
I don't care what you think
it's worth, all right?
I know the challenges of
getting into the wine business.
There's tons of competition,
and very little of it's
proprietary.
But I see the merit of it.
I would use it.
There's more good news ‐‐
I'm gonna make you an offer.
And it's the only offer
I'm gonna make.
I'm not gonna negotiate,
okay?
You've got
to be kidding me.
I'm gonna go
and give you $100,000.
I want 50%.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
You know why?
'Cause you don't know
what you don't know.
And you really need somebody
to actually endorse this
and help you
get it out there.
Yeah, but this ‐‐
this product solves a...
Greiner: All right.
Hold on.
I have some good news
and some bad news.
What do you want first?
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Kevin has made an offer
of $100,000 for a 50% stake
of Alexander's wine‐cooling
product, ProntoBev.
Greiner: All right.
Hold on.
I have some good news
and some bad news.
What do you want first?
Give me the bad news first.
Bad news first.
I'm out.
[ Cuban laughs ]
Lori! What's the good news
from that?
I'll tell you
the good news.
The good news is, I think
you have something clever.
And I think
that it has merit.
I went out because I think
that there's a lot
of time and education
and learning and tweaking
for you to get
to a price point
that I think
will be a ‐‐ a hero.
But I‐I do think...
Are you still out?
...you have the potential
to get there
and you have
a member of the...
Chevaliers.
...Chevaliers du Tastevin!
‐Oh!
‐Hey! Give me a refill.
Now, listen.
Alexander, you do have an offer.
What do you want to do?
There's no way
I have any flexibility.
I've been doing this
my whole life.
Look ‐‐ Well ‐‐
Man, you can't give up
50% of your company, Alexander.
‐I'm s‐‐ It's not a company!
‐But it's a ‐‐
It's Alexander's discussion
with Kevin.
Kevin, if ‐‐ if I gave you
50% of my company...
O'Leary: Right.
...it would be doomed
from that moment.
Why?
Because I need equity
to play around with
so I can raise more money
if I need to.
I gave you 50%.
50% is ‐‐ is not ‐‐
Is there a better partner
than me?
Is there?
20%.
No!
Are you...
No.
No, no, no.
I take you out of the
wastelands, the darkness.
I bring you to the light.
Darkness...light.
‐Oh, my.
That's what's gonna happen.
That's what's going to happen.
You have a high probability
of making money,
versus you walk out the door
with ‐‐ without a deal.
And you are so dead to me.
I won't even remember
this thing.
I'm willing to negotiate,
but I need to keep some equity,
"A," for myself...
You're right!
Yeah, don't be greedy.
...'cause I should have
the majority...
That's Business School 101.
...and, "B," so I can go
and raise the other $100,000.
I have interested people
in the other $100,000.
Look, if you had come
more advanced
with sell‐through and proven
sales, that's different.
I would have give you
more credit
and maybe had flexibility.
You have none of those things,
okay?
Kevin,
are you stuck at the 50%?
I said at the beginning, Robert,
I have no flexibility!
Then give him $200,000
or $250,000.
No!
Greiner: Yeah, give him
the extra $100,000 he needs.
Look.
Simone:
How do I raise the money, Kevin?
If you're gonna be my partner,
I ‐‐ This needs to happen.
Where are I gonna get
the other $100,000?
I get diluted, too.
So we all ‐‐
Maybe I'll go in
on that route.
Maybe I'll put more money
into it. But I'm starting ‐‐
Yeah, now he owns
less than 50%.
It's not his company anymore.
That's his point.
Yeah. Then you're
gonna take more.
Cry me a river, Mark.
Yes or no, Alexander?
You won't budge at all?
O'Leary: None! Zero!
'Cause you're giving me
no wriggle room here.
It's binary ‐‐ yes or no.
This is your moment.
You decide.
What's your next product,
Alexander?
Our next product
is a martini shaker...
What are you talking
to him for? He's already out.
...that ‐‐
that chills martinis.
So ‐‐ So, you need...
You know, the problem
with the martini business
is, wine ‐‐ w‐‐
...to get into
the martini side of it,
and to do this and get it out,
you need another $100,000.
Right.
How are you gonna get
the other $100,000?
We have people
who are interested.
I know I can get
the other $100,000.
Okay.
I know I can.
I'll give you $100,000
for 25%,
contingent that you raise
the other $100,000.
Yeah.
Done.
Greiner: Whoo!
[ Laughs ]
Thank you, Mark.
You got to work
your ass off, okay?
I will, I will.
All right.
I really will.
All right, Alexander.
‐[ Scoffs ]
Simone: I cannot believe I just
made a deal with Mark Cuban.
He went out first.
I was so disappointed.
And he came back in
after listening to everything.
And this terrible deal
I'm trying to make with Kevin.
And it was ‐‐ It's ‐‐
This is the best day of my life.
‐Are you upset?
‐No, not at all.
I would have never done it
for less than 50%.
Kevin, you saved $100,000
that you can spend in the...
Chevaliers du Tastevin!
‐Yay!
‐Whoo!
O'Leary: Cheers.
♪♪